all right monique
yes hello
where are you from where'd you grow up
i'm originally from minnesota i
was born in saint paul but grew up in
the suburbs of the twin cities so about
30 minutes south of there and tell me
about your family well uh i'm 100
croatian
although my father will say yugoslavian
they came here before the war just
before the war so like in the 80s late
80s
and
i always hated that they came decided to
go to minnesota because why so cold so
cold
but i decided to get out as soon as
possible not soon enough i went to
chicago and
for college so i was there for six years
as well and then finally got out of that
into the warmth yeah
yeah it was really just for the weather
what was your childhood like
childhood was
quite
interesting
i
i'm not necessarily an only child i grew
up in a house of all women which is
quite
fascinating i wonder what people thought
of that now growing up i'm like oh
this is that was maybe a bit of an odd
situation but it was my mother was your
father around he was not around no and
he actually lived out here in california
which is why i fell in love with the
state i would come to visit and how can
you not fall in love it's amazing
but
yeah i grew up with my mother and
my half sister who's 19 years older than
me and who has down syndrome and her
mother so
it was the ex-wife and my mother and
father were never actually married so
kind of like
the next girl next woman that they all
went to america together and then i was
born so
yeah it was a very interesting childhood
lots of female energy except for our
pets funny enough which
probably had some influence they were
all boys
and you eventually
how old are you i'm 26 i'll be 27 in
august yeah so you're young you you're
quite young i guess you got into this
interesting
what is it a line of work is it an
attitude is it a well it's a lifestyle
and a line of work i mean it can be both
and for me it is both it can be one or
the other course as well for people but
i
do just find myself to be happiest when
it is both so
yeah and how would you describe it
well i do describe myself as a
professional dominatrix and kink
educator which i do find a lot of my
work ends up being more kink education
than even
straight what you would i mean
definitely not what
most people would
imagine a dominatrix as but at the same
time
there are some of the cliches as well
which is fun of course and part of the
reason i got into it too
so tell me what
what a lot of women and probably men
don't understand about
about
male and female relationships well
male and female relationships i mean
it can go either way of course and i'm
personally very pansexual it's just
extremely
flexible i don't really care what you
have going on if you are a beautiful
person inside and out i
will make it work you know we can make
it work it's not anything no one's seen
before so right you know but
as far as those relationships go it
could be
it doesn't even necessarily have to be
male or female the dynamics
of a more dominant person and a more
submissive person applies to both our
yeah everyone it's not necessarily
everyone because i do find that a lot of
people have
a bit of both you know in them as well
like i myself um i don't consider myself
a switch at all i'm quite dominant but i
know that i'm with for example when i'm
with my partner
i'm often unfortunately i hate i will
never never take this from a man ever
but like as a dom
in my personal life i've been known to
top from the bottom which is annoying as
all hell so you know don't recommend but
it's a dominant problem but that also
does lead to struggles of course
with relationships i mean sexually it's
one thing but
when that bleeds into
everyday life it can cause conflicts but
ultimately what i've learned is that
people
people who tend to be more submissive
really
need to be
want to be
guided and told what to do and
especially
people who are dominant in their
everyday lives maybe are
tired of that and get a little bit
exhausted so when they come home they
want someone who
they don't have to think around they're
telling them exactly what they want
exactly what they need to be doing they
can do it it's really easy everyone's
happy they're happy you know
and you're the girl to do that exactly
of course and so tell me what that gets
into
what kind of behavior
well
what do you mean behavior i mean what
kind of activities yeah what kind of
activities so it can be
anything from i'm quite tall so i
have a lot of requests for height
humiliation for example men who are a
lot shorter than me and want to just be
intimidated by my incredible height and
have me tower over them and just compare
how long and elegant my limbs are in
comparison to them
the term you used before we started this
interview is specification oh
specification yes there's definitely a
lot of that that's so much fun for me
because i'm the girliest
and most like
non-traditional dressing dom that i
really know so sissies are some of my
favorite clients just because i get to
teach them all about makeup and hair and
we get to play dress up which is really
my favorite thing to do i mean i was
telling you earlier i've been doing that
since i was literally like six years old
because i was i'm actually a
second-degree black belt in karate and
so in my karate class there were these
twins i mean it took a long time we were
we were friends for a while but this
started very early on and we were
friends because our parents were friends
but we'd go down into the basement take
out the dress-up box
i'd dress them head to toe in my sparkly
outfits we'd get the whole like nail
polish and makeup on it was so much fun
and they loved it they were boys yeah i
really wonder what happened to them
or how they turned out i'm sure they're
doing well but
it was wonderful and that's basically
what i do now so so both in your
personal relationships as well as your
professional not as much in my personal
relationships i find that the people i
attract personally or at least that i'm
drawn to personally
um
aren't quite as
submissive in the more traditional sense
they're more emotionally submissive and
more like service oriented submission
which i also really love so which
becomes what like a financial yes a
financial thing but also it's not
necessarily like
oh i need this
every week or anything like that it's
like i want a pretty top today it would
make me really happy to go shopping okay
baby here go take that like you know
here's five hundred
dollars yes because it makes me so happy
and then i come home all excited just
smiling ear to ear ready to be like
unwrapped like a present you know so
it's a win-win for everyone involved he
gets what he wants which is me being
super happy and
just incredibly loving and very easy to
not deal with i'm not difficult to deal
with but when i don't get what i want
and i don't feel
adored or loved i'm naturally going to
be a bit
[ __ ] which i think is fair
i think that's fair
and how [ __ ] will you get
well
it really depends on
some
clients probably enjoy that they very
much enjoy that of course the
verbal aspect is really
some the biggest turn on of course it's
the it's all the senses you know it's my
touch it's my voice and really of course
i'm not touching them much at all but
it's just even just the drag of my
finger across their back and they're you
know shaking and can't wait for more but
then that coupled with
an extreme
phrase like calling them
a dirty little [ __ ] or you know things
like that and telling them to open up
like a little [ __ ] [ __ ] and take it
you know they
are gonna get a little bit
they're gonna get i mean a little bit no
they lose their [ __ ] they lose their
minds they like go to another world and
it's so fun to see them
just react like that the reaction's
probably one of my favorite things yeah
and these are married men sometimes
occasionally yes
there are married men which
of course i'm sure people feel
all sorts of types of ways about but for
me i find it
very interesting to get to know like
what what led them here you know instead
of talking to their partner but that's
what do you think led some of these men
into this uh truly just feeling
discomfort in talking about what they're
into
with their partner or fear of rejection
or
you know anything like that these are
probably successful absolutely you know
they're powerful people absolutely like
really i mean i have ndas for reasons
you know on deck always because of the
people especially here in l.a you know
um
but
yeah i really i feel for them and i do
take it as an opportunity that's the
kink education as well i like to i have
a million pamphlets and little things
from whatever little you know the sex
workers outreach project and things like
that people who just want to inform and
help other people
be able to
openly talk about their sexual desires
with their loved ones and the people
they care about in order to find
something that
works for them so i do
actually really like when because this
has happened before where a client will
come to me and
will go through the session and talk
about you know they're married and talk
about what brought them here and their
past bdsm experiences and i will go
ahead and coach them on how to talk to
their partner about that and how to
maybe incorporate
what we did in a way that is safe and
comfortable and you know a nice slow
transition that's not gonna like maybe
shock someone right away or anything but
i've actually seen clients
not come back then and but then like
text me and say it's going really really
well you know i thank you and then of
course spend money and whatever just for
thanks but
i'm happy to lose a client that way
because
you know that's
kind of the goal is to well my goal at
least is
healing and
sexual education and liberation to a
point there's certain things of course
that
this is probably more common than we
assume
what the
the amount of people who are into oh my
god yeah absolutely it's i'm
shocked at the sheer
number of fetishes there are for
all sorts of things people are always
shocked when i can literally just make
hundreds and hundreds of dollars off of
a video of me just smoking a cigarette
and pretending the camera is an ashtray
well a person who i'm making my ashtray
human ashtray
is a fetish of course you know
so they're gonna eat my ash and
potentially even the cigarette but it's
wild but of course we discuss
boundaries before the scene you know and
i'm not pushing anyone to just like put
a cigarette out on them or something
crazy it's a sexual thing for most of
your clients oh yes it is it's
definitely which is why i consider it
sex work it's definitely a sexual thing
they're obviously getting off on what
i'm providing them just because i'm not
having intercourse with them there are i
mean i do pegging so i do have a
silicone [ __ ] that does [ __ ] them you
know like not my person but at the same
time i'm sure i mean they consider it a
very intimate experience so
what do you think went on in their lives
that they
enjoy being
humiliated or dominated by a female
usually from my experience it comes from
either someone who has been humiliated
by beautiful women in the past so
someone who's always been like
really undesired not undesirable but
like
you know traditionally speaking less
attractive to women or
hasn't like i wouldn't go so far as to
say in cells because they're not like
that and i don't [ __ ] with clients like
that absolutely not
but
they do have that kind of
melancholy
sexlessness about them that you can see
it's
something that they've decided to
embrace almost and they're like well if
this is all i can get
i'm gonna
do it right you know i'm gonna get the
hottest dom that i can get and i'm going
to
pay her money to
get that experience that i really won't
get anywhere else so that's one side of
it but then
another side of it is again people who
have had
so much power and so many
like people who are really rich or
powerful have a lot of money have had
women come and go you know throw
themselves at them but still not be able
to
there's always like an expectation there
still you know what i'm saying so and
and still
not just an expectation of finances or
you know status quo in the relationship
but also that masculinity if they want
to be specified or something they're
going to find it potentially hard to go
to
a woman who they perceive as very much
not
accustomed to that most women probably
aren't accustomed to it
but
i really don't know why i am so okay
with that what do you what what in your
life happened that made you discover
that men are into this
are there that there are men
that are into this
well
i
have been
a very sexually
exploited explorative explorative
adventurous adventurous that's the word
thank you very sexually adventurous from
an early age yes and uh obviously that's
something there's a reason sex can
become an addiction and i also am
careful not to
deal with clients who are clearly
addicted to this and using it as an
escape or an unhealthy kind of
thing
but
i you asked how i got how i realized
what what happened in your life that led
you down this path that made you aware
that this was something that some men
are into yes so
like i said i did you have a partner
that
so i started
entering i entered in the bdsm scene not
in a dominant way necessarily i also i
guess if you say entering the bdsm scene
again i've been sissifying men since an
early age but it wasn't in that context
so it's not really the same thing but
it wasn't because
it kind of is well yeah i mean it is
exactly i'm sure they were it is
absolutely
to a point but we didn't know what we
were doing when you were young when you
were a teenager 20s you were early 20s
you were early 20s i wasn't necessarily
submissive but because i actually
weirdly didn't have
any male attention in like middle school
or high school at all because you're so
tall probably also 362. yeah and in
minnesota i just like stick out like a
sore thumb in general just the way i i
am i don't know something about it
i don't know but
yeah i
as soon as i graduated high school i
started just kind of overcompensating
for that and just being like oh you're
into me okay cool let's do it and that
was that was like an ego boost for me
but at the same time i was just doing
whatever they were doing frankly
learning and some of them would just
start like
like slapping the [ __ ] out of me without
asking without talking about it i
realized i liked it but i was like
still what about my face says please
just
start beating the [ __ ] out of me while
we're [ __ ] i don't know not sure what
about that is a thing but i realized i
liked it i'm like okay let's
let's see what this is about okay bdsm
it should be consensual and now i learn
a lot more and then i started just
exploring it more
so there's
it wasn't until
i got to
la though it's been three years now that
i've been doing this professionally but
it wasn't until i got here that i
actually was like wait this is a career
that i could do as well because i really
did think it was all the
leather latex all the time you have to
be an all black i look great in black
but i look great in so many other colors
you know come on i want to wear way more
than that and my personal style i think
there's something
that
you're not wearing hip-high black boots
no sometimes sometimes i do have like my
black boots on but i'll usually have
like a vintage lace something with that
you know to add my personal touch with
it i like to you also dress normally
sometimes sometimes i do yeah it really
depends on
the scene that we're doing of course
like foot fetish type things like if
it's a soul licking situation i can
easily be like this and just lick my
tennis shoes you know that kind of thing
so it doesn't really matter what i'm
wearing but then a ball busting
situation i'm going to want my black
boots with my spikes on them so i can
make sure i'm doing it right you know um
yeah so
you you like being hit you you discover
yes okay so i discovered that i like
pain and i'm like oh
but during sex and specific pain you
know
and also
yeah so i'm a bit of a masochist to to
that extent but then i'm
i also experienced a bit of physical
abuse growing up so i'm sure that's
where that comes from it's like
i hate you because i love you you know
that kind of a thing so i'm sure there's
a connection there uh but also
kind of like a training thing like this
is what
i mean that's how i was that's the
reason i was hit like to be
trained i guess to do what i was told to
do which
repression repression's a good word to
describe my childhood very repressed
yeah
uh which i think is another reason that
i did go so far this way because if i
was a la if i were allowed to explore
and
was educated i went to catholic school
my entire life so and my family is very
religious and very conservative so this
is quite the uncomfortable situation for
them but
i just realized that
it's human and it's healthy and it's
beautiful and when it's done in a safe
and consensual
relationship no one's getting hurt no
it's really really really helpful
actually for a lot of people because of
where it does come from that's what i
was going to say the other side of the
coin is that
these rich and powerful men
are kind of sick of
being of having to be the dominant one
at home as well or being spoiled for
choice with women too it's kind of nice
to have a bit of a challenge to have
someone it's gonna be refreshing yeah
it's very refreshing it's nice to have
someone tell you exactly what they want
you to do and make you their little
[ __ ] and probably just relax and enjoy
realigns them mentally and then they can
go back to kicking ass next week
absolutely it's a nice release exactly a
nice refreshing break so when you
realize that you enjoy being hit did you
also kind of eventually discover that
absolutely
oh for sure for sure for sure and it got
really
i realized how much i love doing that to
men especially because i have an
incredibly high pain tolerance like
incredibly high so i can take it but
then when i go back and dish it like
consensually also they're [ __ ]
[ __ ] about it and it's hilarious to
me so i love
to
test men's pain tolerance not like in a
scary way but like i'm like okay rate
that for me scale of one to ten what's
comfy for you okay we like to keep it
out of six that's so funny you think
that's a six you [ __ ] little [ __ ] oh
my god
it's really the most extreme
in general
just like your clients or with your
partners whatever so the most extreme
thing i've seen with my partners is
way more messed up than what i've seen
with my clients believe it or not so i
always tell people that
the human toilet situations that request
always [ __ ] me mentally a little bit
i'm willing to do it but you have to
prep obviously to make sure that you're
safe and that the situation is as safe
as it can be but like how safe can that
really be i mean
it's yeah so that's a little extreme but
most people are more shocked by the cbt
stuff which is [ __ ] ball torture um not
to be confused with cognitive behavioral
therapy as someone who goes to
a lot always i'm like we're talking
cockball torture here this is really odd
um but no uh
they love extreme ball busting like i've
literally seen people who are like
please make sure i can't have kids like
they'll tell people that they've been in
a motorcycle accident after it so
it's uh very extreme that's that's very
extreme so you'll be hitting there oh
yes i'll just be
picking that well with my boots i've got
the spikes for it sometimes it's a
crushing situation
as well which is just like a stepping
and grinding type of thing and you you
enjoy giving this out
i mean it's entertaining is all hell i
guess but
more so it's just i know they want that
they're gonna go somewhere for it
they're asking for it and [ __ ] i can do
it well so might as well right i'm not
gonna say no to that
but
yeah i don't like have the
everyday desire to just like
kick some random guy in the balls now
these guys probably become regulars they
do they do absolutely yeah it's hard
well
as regular as you can be
they need some recovery time with that
kind of thing which understandable
really understandable i'm super
comfy with that
but
the most [ __ ] up thing personally that
happened to me i consider to be
[ __ ] up
yes because of i've never even gotten
this request in my work which that's why
i'm like whoa but more so because
this was someone i was dating
like casually we weren't anything super
serious but it was like three months of
seeing each other pretty regularly and
um
he knew what i did for work so maybe
that set a little bit of a precedent
however
one night we came home and we were both
pretty drunk and we'd eaten a ton
so
we were really full but we start hooking
up and he starts putting his fingers in
my mouth and
whatever but he keeps going like farther
and farther
at first i thought he was just kind of
being funny about it because like don't
have much of a gag reflex thanks to the
bulimia for years and years and years
but um
i thought he was just being like kind of
funny about it but
he wasn't he just kept going at a
certain point like he's got his whole
hand like in my [ __ ] mouth and i'm
like shaking my head trying to say no i
can't actually speak
but i'm telling him that like it's gonna
happen and it does happen so like i
throw up a bit but i'm not a rookie i
can hold it in my mouth and swallow it
down right and uh he slaps me
immediately and he goes no that's mine
and i'm so confused because i mean i'm
i think i get what he means but i just
like can't imagine that that's what he
means
but i was like no no i i
definitely said no like verbally said no
no no like trying to
have a conversation but couldn't finish
my son's hands in the mouth again like
all the way down again and this time
immediately it a lot more came up and he
grabs my face and kisses me and
sucks it all from my mouth and swallows
it
and i'm in utter [ __ ] shock because
what
yeah i don't know i don't know i really
don't i don't i don't know um that's a
crazy one that is really crazy when it
happened four more times in between i'm
saying no and [ __ ] like literally no no
stop stop stop stop what are you doing
no no no whoa whoa he's not stopping and
like i'm sure it's probably because i
have a bit of a cnc kink we had talked
about that before that's consensual
non-consensual that's because i have
been
raped and
more minorly sexually assaulted like
way too many times to count
unfortunately so
when i was younger yes um a lot younger
how old are you how old was i the first
time was 17. so not that young but it
stopped finally at like
well unfortunately the last one was in
2019 in san diego i got date raped which
sucked i was like gh i know what a roofy
date rape is like but this is my first
time with ghb
ladies ghb is a thing
and i don't even know how to describe
that feeling but it wasn't until
six months later that i was
it was coveted and i was just like
vibing with a friend and he was like you
want to do some ghb i'm like never done
it i'll try and then i took it and i'm
like oh [ __ ] i've totally done it
so i'm not just a junk [ __ ] after one
martini i that's why i don't remember a
single [ __ ] thing that makes sense
how many other girls did he do that to
how many other women just never [ __ ]
knew that they were fully drugged
because i've never experienced that
feeling before you could barely taste it
it was just and i've never felt
yeah i don't even know how to describe
it but you passed out oh yeah fully no
but like in the middle of like like
i'm six foot two i used to be a
bartender like i have a very high
tolerance for liquor and most drugs too
but um you're not supposed to mix those
two together and also ghb never will
touch never will touch but um
yeah
it was didn't even finish my martini
never left the table in my mind i was
still at the table woke up in
some dude's bed you know so i was still
at the table but [ __ ] uh yeah so that
sucked but otherwise they stopped around
22.
so 23.
that wasn't too bad
um no 22 yeah
yeah
so
that's good but you know i had to learn
pretty quickly
that
just because you say no
nicely doesn't really mean [ __ ]
you have to be a bit of a scary forceful
[ __ ] sometimes with these people
so
now that [ __ ] doesn't happen again and i
really would love to see someone try
because my bpd is just begging for a
reason you know
um but
this has made you a little more
assertive
oh my god of course if if those things i
mean i'm not happy that they no but
you're with this this whole discovery of
yours of course yeah you're probably a
little more able to take oh definitely
my work oh my gosh yeah doing that and
really diving into it i
it's changed everything like now i could
never date the same way that i used to
i'm a completely different person now
you know i always was
incredibly dominant my mother is a very
dominant woman she is the matriarch and
the patriarch she is
everything you know um
but
now yeah i could never go back never go
back these
always got my men on a [ __ ] leash now
basically just as they should be right
in the best most loving ways what would
you say is the most important lesson
you've learned in all of this
uh not to
judge people i mean i never really did
before but
i just
see how much pain it's i know how much
pain has caused me being judged but i've
gotten over it thanks to philosophy and
a whole lot of weed every day and just
not giving a [ __ ] anymore um actually
just
probably uh
probably exposure therapy just extreme
exposure therapy just you can't really
you have to really
really [ __ ] with me to get to me now you
know um but
a lot of people
haven't gone through that same thing or
have and are just [ __ ] tired and
you gotta realize that everyone's human
and everyone is dealing with the human
experience and
we all are kind of basically
a collective consciousness to a point
having
very similar experiences whether we know
it or not and
i think just having more empathy and
less judgment through all of that is the
most important thing granted i again
already knew that but it was just really
solidified and it makes me happy to be
able to share that with people too
all right monique thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you thank you
for having me super interesting yeah i
would love to talk more oh my god
forever and ever thank you yes of course
thank you
you